it's never the gear you know people glad
the gear i'm going to start running but
i need to get the running shoes before I
can start running the stems is always a
way start with a bookcase just start you
don't have to wait next week until that
order from amazon comes in do something
right now start right go down key and
buy something and start and test it
right people always blame the gear I'm
not gonna get on YouTube until I get a
video camera you have a phone start
recording start right I'm not going to
start a podcast till I get the
microphone and get the software and get
to whatever just start there's always
something that's going to hold you back
just start I love that mentality you
you've actually inspired me I should
probably get fix something up and start
standing up because I've been thinking
about it and I've been saying all those
desks are so expensive where am I gonna
put it and it just kind of fell by the
wayside so guys all the Giants listening
remember that just take action take
immediate action and then correct course
as you go